Prime Minister's just returned from
Downing Street and immediately after
seeing her Majesty which was not
technically necessary nonetheless using
the prime ministerial pulpits to send a
message to Britain that there was a
quote unquote stark choice about who
ends up walking through that black door
in may just him or Ed Miliband and he
claims as he's claimed for a few months
now that that would mean economic chaos
chaos not just from the Labour Party bar
chaos of a Labour Party supported in
some way or form by the SNP but labour
of hit back today as well saying
actually the conservative to have their
own brand of chaos which is a referendum
on the EU at the same time as a divisive
leadership contest because David Cameron
has announced he'll only be see trying
to seek out a second term and not a
third term so those are the two sorts of
contours of day one of the campaign
competitive negative campaigning about
what the other side will do could that
well be why both sides are stuck below
thirty five percent failing to win this
election lead into a contest of who
loses the most can they do anything to
punch up above and actually grasp this
election for themselves surely they can